bienvenidos a los pan de mis un programa
de premiación diferente para la noche
más glamorosa de la televisión como
todos los demás la pandemia de
coronavirus obligó a la versión número
72 de los emmy a adaptarse la bienvenida
del anfitrión jimmy kimmel por un
auditorio de estrellas pronto se reveló
como un material de archivo
jaime no perdió el tiempo en ponerse
político por supuesto no tenemos
audiencia esta noche este es el lema no
mitin de hacer américa grande otra vez
el programa se hizo eficazmente en la
llamada de zoom más glamorosa del mundo
ya que más de 100 estrellas participaron
en el vídeo desde más de 10 países el
gran ganador de la noche fue el drama de
superhéroes de hb o watchmen que obtuvo
11 premios incluida la mejor serie
limitada y parecía ser la noche de hb o
su programa en los que cuenta la jugosa
historia de una familia mediática
rebelde fue galardonada con una serie
dramática sobresaliente así como premios
por guión y dirección otro gran ganador
fue el programa canadiense
que hizo historia de ganar siete premios
en la categoría de comedia en su sexta y
última temporada se siente como un sueño
del que no quiere despertar no creo que
puedas pedir una mejor conclusión para
una historia pero esta noche con las
elecciones estadounidenses que se
avecinan la política hizo ocasionalmente
irrupción en la ceremonia algunas
estrellas mostraron signos de apoyo al
movimiento black life matter y otras
incitaron a la gente a votar cuando se
celebren las elecciones el 3 de
noviembre